-Today is Friday.
I call it "Fri-yay."
-Fri-yay.
-Yeah.
-I call it Fri-Fri,
but either way,
I always have to write,
I have to catch up with
some personal stuff.
I have to write out
some thank you notes,
so right now,
if you don't mind,
can I write them out
in the middle of the show?
[ Applause ]
I'm sorry.
James, can I get some thank you
note writing music, please?
[ Gentle piano music plays ]
Ooh, he's ready for the weekend.
-Oh, man.
-He's ready for the weekend.
-Mr. Friday Night.
-No tie.
-Thank's how you get ready
for the weekend?
-Yeah, he takes his tie off
and just goes for it, man.
Boop.
Thank you, Indy 500 drivers,
for drinking milk
after the race,
which, thanks to inflation,
is basically champagne,
so there you guys go.
[ Applause ]
Thank you,
American flag toothpicks,
for making it look like
the moon landing
happened on my hamburger.
[ Applause ]
That's one small --
-Bun for man.
-Thank you, the series finale
of "This is Us"
for not being called
"That Was We."
[ Laughter ]
That was...
Thank you, White Claw's
new line of drinks
called "White Claw Refrshrs,"
for being low in calories,
carbs, and vowels, apparently.
[ Applause ]
[ Chuckles ]
Thank you,
graduation caps and dunce caps,
for measuring intelligence
by hat pointiness.
[ Applause ]
[ Chuckles ] Dunce caps.
[ Both laugh ]
Thank you, croquet mallets,
for showing me what it
would look like
if Thor joined a country club.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughing ]
Thank you, backyard barbecues,
for being like the Met Gala
of dads wearing aprons.
There you go.
[ Applause ]
Thank you, crosswalk timer,
for looking like a countdown
to a high-five.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are our thank you notes!